die nächste Eskalationsstufe der
klimaproteste ist erreicht Aktivisten
der letzten Generation wollen mit einem
Presslufthammer eine Straße mitten in
Berlin aufmeißeln die Polizei kann sie
gerade noch rechtzeitig stoppen
mehrere Aktivisten bauen eine falsche
Baustelle in Berlin auf mitten auf einer
Hauptverkehrsstraße gegenüber vom
Verkehrsministerium
eine gefährliche Aktion denn für die
Autofahrer im Berufsverkehr ist zunächst
nicht zu erkennen ob die Baustelle echt
ist oder nur eine Demo Attrappe
die Berliner Polizei ist schnell vor Ort
gerade noch rechtzeitig denn einer der
Männer schmeißt einen Presslufthammer an
will die Straße aufstemmen der Polizist
muss ihn entschlossen davon abhalten
dann geben sich die Aktivisten zu
erkennen eine neue krasse Eskalation der
klimaaktivisten die jetzt sogar Straßen
zerstören wollen um auf Ihre Ziele
hinzuweisen